[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
beaucoup
au mieux actuellement le blanc et de
prendre 20 patients sur ce premier train
la région de grand test et au pic de sa
vague qu'on va tous connaître
probablement dans nos régions dans les
semaines qui viennent
et l'idée est justement de jouer sur le
décalage des régions pour prendre des
malades et régions qui sont en plein pic
épidémique les transporter vers des
régions entre guillemets plus calme
actuellement et qu'après ce jeu de
rotation puisse avoir lieu sur tout le
territoire national voire européen
mais ces déchets
comment
[Musique]
mon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est dans le tram vous verrez que les
patients ne bouge pas il n'y a pas de
décélération il ya pas de choses comme
ça et que pour travailler on est quand
même beaucoup mieux qu'on hélicoptère
[Musique]
peu de temps voici
vous